hey guys it's Justine and today we are
checking out the brand-new Sony Master
Series a 9f OLED TV it is right here
it's in front of me I'm excited because
my sister and I actually got a chance to
see this at their New York launch event
a few months ago and since then I have
been waiting very very patiently so
today is the day where we actually get
to unbox it and set it up right here
behind me Sony wanted to create a TV
that preserved the creator's intent so I
make videos for living so when I am
editing something and I see it on a
different screen or TV it's normally not
exactly how I intended it to look so
that happens a lot with movies or TV
shows but with this it'll give you a
perfectly calibrated view of exactly
what the person who created it wanted
you to see so let's test this out let's
get a nice funny I think there's some I
need your help Jen so this is the 65
inch and it is going to look so
beautiful there may be a little bit of
construction that we have to do Jen yes
I told you we were gonna watch Netflix
but not yet oh no there's more back here
are you ready okay let's move this over
here we've got more cables yes is the
stand child safety we don't have
children
this is a nice piece of cardboard this
is what you put on the back because the
cool thing about this is there's a
center speaker so when you're listening
to the audio it's actually coming
straight through the TV as opposed to at
the bottom or from the sides you're
hindering my ability um okay put it down
oh yeah that's that's the ticket we're
still here please are you swimming in I
hope so once we get done setting this up
we're gonna wait until it gets dark so
we'll be able to have a really great
test environment so I just want to go to
dinner there's video yeah that's like it
is gonna be a nice test environment I'm
sure we're just rests we just rest for
more that's pretty good Wow here's a
problem there's a lot of cables back
here yes what's that
is it HDMI yeah I'm gonna feed you
another one how many more HDMI slots do
we have left I think we use three yeah
there's another HDMI over here this is
lovely
oh yeah she's ready maybe we should
clean up first I wish you have dinner
first made a really big mess daddy
well I think we're finally ready to
watch TV got all these stickies oh yeah
oh yeah get it yeah Wow we've got
everything set up and now the first
thing that we have to do is test out the
Netflix calibrated mode what should we
watch this is all you wanted was to
watch Netflix finally lost in space
let's click it action menu we're gonna
go to picture adjustments clicking
Netflix calibrated do you see it or are
you ready turn off all my lights
[Music]
it also looks good from almost any angle
- Wow like look I can be over over here
it's so crazy because usually I'm so
used to having like a sound bar and with
no sound bar it still sounds incredible
it's so weird because the audio is
coming from the center of the television
which is such a strange thing
[Music]
it sounds like this whole room has
surround sound and it does not it's just
coming from this
[Applause]
[Music]
so like I was saying the audio is in the
center of the television the sound is
basically traveling through the TV to me
right here it's called acoustic surface
audio plus this thing is pretty awesome
I like that there's no stand that you
can see it's kind of just like hidden in
the back but the stand doubles as a
subwoofer the glass is actually the
speaker and three actuators cause the
screen to vibrate to project sound from
different parts of the screen so the
audio really does feel like it's coming
at you so all of this is made possible
by Sony's new 4k HDR processor called
the x1 ultimate it has three major
features object-based HDR a masters old
database processing and super bit
mapping 4k HDR now this can be a little
bit technical but what this really means
for you guys at home is that you get an
incredible realistic viewing experience
the object based HDR though is really
fascinating it analyzes each object each
scene individually and it'll enhance the
color and the contrast so that the darks
get darker the whites get brighter and
everything is incredibly accurate to
real life let's take this thing for a
fortnight test I'm excited because now
PlayStation has finally allowed the
cross play between all platforms so you
can play against everyone thank you
PlayStation this is the first time that
I've played for tonight on PlayStation
the bus is leaving
no swimming okay it doesn't even matter
it's done sucks I'm gonna go get this
person
I probably shouldn't because I don't
have a good gun well that's one night
and it looks freakin fantastic
I don't want to stop playing but I've
got to continue my video we watched some
TV we played some fortnight let's watch
a movie I watched like so many seasons
of arrow back to back that I was
concerned about my well-being oh yeah
can you try not light off oh wow see the
vision from the Pentagon is best I'm
just so shocked by this audio like it
sounds incredible I'm gonna fast-forward
to some action it also has built-in
Google assistant so you can basically
talk to your TV hi how can I help
oh no I was reading what you were saying
to me I was reading we were saying to me
results for hi how can I help oh wait
Nickelback iJustine so this TV is
running Android oh the previous version
was Android N and I have another Sony TV
those in my kitchen and it is a lot
slower than this one so I've already
noticed that this version of Android is
so much faster so that is really great
news
I'm so excited I'm watching my own movie
on my own TV Thank You Jenna for helping
me with the TV i enticed her by telling
her that we were going to be watching
Netflix in dinner and guess what we did
both of those you know more information
about this TV I'll put a link in the
description and I'll see you guys later
cuz I'm gonna finish watching my own
YouTube videos like I haven't ever seen
my videos before CES felt like such a
long time ago
[Music]